[Music]
and assassination fail new you submitted
by hey Julio how you Julio Bennett who
you hey Julia how you doing alright
former Power Ranger Jason David Frank
opens up about the alleged assassination
attempt on him Rangers he what
generation marine he's a configuration
Tommy
yeah but Tommy turned into the White
Ranger yes Jason is the red man Jason
the red right area and then Billy is the
Blue Ranger Trina is a yellow Kimball
evil pink yeah so this guy looks like
this guy right here looks like mommy
saves like resolution into this look at
him
yeah oh my gosh I can't see it anymore
wow really nathan is a thing to me he
kept though he kept a little goatee
being the exact I mean that was him over
15 years ago then I was in elementary
school when that she came out through
that generation that was the first one
it's morphin time
have you guys seen the episodes they
have it on Netflix it's very it's very
very very very hard to watch oh no I
love this extrude recording like it made
me cringe super bad we had to have a
school assembly because too many kids
were playing Power Rangers and it turned
into real life I think the whole fight
that was happy not good it was it was
not allowed to play Power Rangers any
more flowing division Power Rangers and
it'd be like 15 Reverend we're all
fighting each other nobody wanted to be
anyone elses green ranger notice before
the green a jerk a medal that was like
the leader so everyone was wanted to be
anything no one else no one wanted to be
any other 800 there's a pause mind you
talk about the guy that's done yeah it
was funny because he would dance and
fight at the same time he was don't but
them was a full-on fight on your go to
school like yeah it would it would start
off as just like they're playing but it
got aggressive and more more crazy and
like the kids would just start fighting
but they're like oh you hit me for real
I'm gonna hit you back for real
and then like no kids fighting is pretty
fun I'll turn into like a rumble
[ __ ] intelligent yeah so there was this
attempted murder on this food by this 29
year old named Matthew at the Phoenix
Comic Con so oh man you know what I
thought was going to happen
I thought Rita was sending her foot
soldiers over to [ __ ] assassinate
Tommy after all these years was
happening real real life I'm kind of
disappointed but anyways this guy
Matthew he was like totally mentally
unstable because he went to the Comic
Con dress as a Punisher he had katana
weapons and he somehow about pass
security she's like a real weapons they
were real what so he had a shotgun three
45 caliber handguns a combat knife
pepper spray and throwing stars he was
also where I already spoke at at
comic-con I don't think I ever got
checked at comic-con
dude well at this particular comic-con
they did say that at that time they
didn't have the middle John hmm they
weren't they weren't checking all
because this is in Arizona too when you
go Lindy hmm yeah so then after this
whole thing happened then I started
implementing that but anyway so I went
in with multiple guns he went him with
multiple gun he was also wearing body
armor high on his clothes
how did you not see the Punisher thisn I
said skin tight yeah but they probably
started as parties costume yeah well let
me tell you what he looks like
that he is nothing like oh no wonder no
I would ask them what are you what is
your costume yes usually brain no you
say what gods it in like sir are you in
a pleasure yes I am but [ __ ] with a
bunch of pound cake baby I got it
really they wanted gonna punish like a
little earlier this guy was punishing
those shoes photos you can pay me get
your [ __ ] fat ass out here motion
pictures of like it yeah or your wife
that's what I'm suggesting I pictured
like boots for some reason these guys
wear boots and the boots are like ah Oh
God we see they're so wide that the lace
is barely tying together yeah cute
little both okay yeah so apparently this
dude she was sending Facebook messages
to someone I'm not sure the relation but
she was any place unless messages to
someone and so police and Phoenix
received a call from the police
department in Hawthorne here in
California hoping that they were warning
them about Matthew and the fact that
there was witness saying that you know
he was sending him messages saying that
he was going to be in a showdown with
cops and would kill them Wow and she was
sending pictures of like the cops there
saying like oh yeah I'm going to kill
that guy and things like that
luckily the cops are able to stop him
before she did anything before he
injured anyone and they found on his
cell phone that he had a calendar
reminder set saying I killed JVs that
was on his calendar Wow Jason David
Frank JC for God like maybe someone
wanted to schedule the lunch who was
haunted oh yeah
the Green Ranger what a [ __ ] yeah so
luckily he wasn't there Jason Davis
Frank wasn't there he ended up showing
up late for whatever reasons they always
do well he's like that strong believer
in God that he was just saying that God
shifted his schedule to save him no it
was just hung over him the night before
that's what happens all artists they
never perform on time go to Carnegie
concert he's going to be the chazak so
I'm going to show you guys his
statements that he gave to the press he
just saved me thank you very much first
of all I'm very grateful to the Phoenix
Police Department for their brave and
outstanding efforts you better end with
more sometime boy is a terrible tragedy
[Laughter]
is recently seen at the concert in
Manchester to all my fans please if you
see something say something and this
helped avoid a dangerous situation
that's right for the pending allegations
I will only state I do not personally
know the person who was arrested but I
will pray for him I will not let the
situation stop me from meeting all my
fans I will continue my regular schedule
at Phoenix Comic Con for the duration of
the show but if you guys have any
questions regarding this case please
contact sergeant fortune of the Phoenix
Police Department you have fortune this
thank you to everybody and be assured
one thing this this has not affected me
in any manner so that's what I like to
say that's a badass last me the time I
thought well I thought he was gonna stay
just let's be assured it's morphin time
but he didn't say that so I'm your China
oh man that's like the oddest person to
target - and I also forgot to mention
that Matthew was saying and he was
telling the cop set that he had stabbed
Jason 15 years ago and he was going back
to finish the job and Jason was like
nobody starts now Vince dad no he's
crazy
yeah not down crazy not so Matthew has
been booked on charges of attempted
murder aggravated assault with a deadly
weapon wearing body armor during the
commission of a felony resisting arrest
and carrying a weapon unique prohibited
please dude this guy is gonna get [ __ ]
up in prison that is you have a real
criminal yeah he's just a nerd with a
gun sleepy people isn't a titty [ __ ] I
know yeah I must [ __ ] them everywhere
else welcome Mexico looks like I have
hairy potato dude it's ever look like a
hairy [ __ ] potato eight inmates on
that floor yo they're gonna find the
crease and start [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of
each little [ __ ] creep yeah we got a
trolls going down from the titty down to
the belly they're gonna all have a dick
inside every single one gonna lay them
flat on the table and start [ __ ]
working I'm like a [ __ ] oh my god Katy
Perry again here's a video of her skin
turns into don't ya all you talk to you
about such condition - oh dude I [ __ ]
love my life performance
dude that conformity killed my appetite
they did look like a like a old white
soccer
like dancing China be like hood it just
i had never laughed so hard in it i
don't know why maybe it was just that
night and I just watched it I didn't
hear anything about it I was just like
oh [ __ ] Katy Perry because I thought
she's real pretty and that's not Miley
Cyrus on stage no wait that's not - I
just keep hearing like what happened to
her so I just watch another like also
about that bad and then out of nowhere
all set I don't have too much swag this
is good too much she went like this is
good I would just like no that's the
most why she's up yeah like her legs are
so open - she's a psycho is a few crazy
[ __ ] I love you like a mom getting down
on a birthday party
hello JK news fans now I know you want
to be a part of our videos and you know
how you do that you go to the [ __ ]
link below and use [ __ ] submit some
articles other than that go check out
our videos up here hell yeah
[Music]